[Musique]
la musique de la ligue des champions
pour débuter ce match capital trappe
recevait les mureaux lors de l'ultime
journée de r3 en cas de victoire
associée à une défaite de boulogne
billancourt les trappistes pouvait être
champion
une source de motivation pour les
joueurs qui mène à rapidement un puis
deux puis 3 0 après une première période
spectaculaire chose maintenant faciliter
non plus comment ça a déjoué
certes pour rien à jouer ça permet de
garder supplications et de leur dire que
au delà du fait de terminer meilleure
défense aussi de j'aime cette première
place et qui se passe vraiment vraiment
est amplement méritée et tout le mérite
leur en revient
de retour sur le terrain trappe se fait
surprendre sur corner par les mureaux
l'équipe de hicham et redit souffre mais
arrivent à faire la différence en contre
les trappistes inscriront le dernier but
de leur saison en fin de match score
final 4-1 de son côté boulogne
billancourt s'inclinent 4 à 2 sur le
terrain tony trappe terminent premiers
du championnat
[Applaudissements]
on récupère cette première place qu'on a
occupé les trois quarts de l'année ça
fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite en
revient aux joueurs au staff aussi kim a
un qui m'accompagne à la direction qui
m'a fait confiance cette année est
vraiment fier aussi de terminer
meilleure défense de la ligue de paris
sur la saison n'a encaissé 12 buts et
c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est vraiment
peu et c'est une grosse saison 0 5 buts
par match c'est ce qui a fait notre
force soutient cette saison très fier de
temps tant d'années qu'on cherchait sa
le club
il est beaucoup d'investissement de
joueurs d'efforts de sueur de rigueur et
away très fier de faire pas vraiment
monter ce club moi l'équipe la régionale
2 un niveau attendu par les trappistes
depuis 35 ans pour réussir sa saison
prochaine le staff veut conserver son
groupe en y ajoutant de l'expérience
avec un objectif en tête le 20e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]